did you guys see the drones falling out
of the sky in china yeah so because i
keep thinking drone delivery is the wave
of the future but apparently yeah this
story's light show goes wrong when
drones start plumbing out of the sky the
one guy that tweeted said word on the
streets that a rival drone company that
lost the bid interfered to overwhelm the
drone's nav system
and they all came well they didn't come
fall at plummeting down they all kind of
like spun down they had their own yeah
like so basically it looks like they
were told to land so we have the video
this is actually a crazy story man this
is interesting drones raining from the
sky in zhengzhao word on the street as
ian mentioned a rival drone company lost
the bid interfered and overwhelmed the
drones nav system people are like
dodging out of the way the drones are
crashing down interesting
i don't think people are prepared for
what all this new technology really
means
when we started we started me and my
friends were experimenting with drone
tech back in like 2011 early consumer
drones really light really crappy would
blow away it was like you know
we knew like if we're gonna use these
things they can fall you've got four
rotors on these drones
if one of them goes out it falls
so now they've got this video of a guy
and he's riding you see the guy riding
the quadcopter yeah or it's an
octocopter it's got four rotors but it's
got two blades on each side and then
they're like you know it was an
experiment for helping fight fires and
i'm like dude if one of those goes out
you die
because the crazy thing about that thing
he was sitting in was that there were no
cages around the blades so if he pitches
forward and the blade goes into his back
i don't know how big it was surface wise
but
yo this video is nuts man i mean i saw i
saw a drone light show at burning man a
few years ago and it was it was
something else i mean just being able to
see drones in unison dancing and having
this light show presented to you this
year at the renegade burning man they
did another one uh where they did the
man and they
burned it but it was drones flying up in
the air so there's a lot of this
technology i know the pentagon has been
talking about weaponizing small drones
and using it
as a way to attack people where you
can't even defend against it so this new
technology will have a lot of different
ramifications that we can't even
foretell in our modern society so the
way that things could go i mean it's so
unpredictable you ever play watch dogs
i've seen so the first the first you
play is like a hacker and you you hack
stuff and it's like you know really
basically it's a game where like you can
change the street lights and like open
doors
but in watch dogs 2
you get remote explosives you get drones
you get a ground drone and a
quadcopter drone and you can launch the
drone throw an explosive on it and then
fly it at you know your opponents or
your enemies or whatever and what people
i i wonder if they really realize that
in the game that like yo that's
happening yeah like in the middle east
drones are going up and into military
bases and stuff like this this
technology stuff man i don't think
people are prepared for what's going to
happen in big cities
they're going to need like
signal grids like
invisible radio wave force fields that
when a drone gets too close it just
just goes down
otherwise it'll go in the city and well
already dgi has geo locations where it
can't operate in
specifically near near prisons
especially near uh airports because
there's been a lot of people also using
these drones they fly them over prisons
and they uh
drop drugs
and other uh weapons uh into the the
field
um so there's been a lot of different
but you can they can be hacked they can
be manipulated of course there's there's
what people don't realize too is like
the consumer ones oh yeah if you buy a
consumer drone it's not gonna fly in
certain places but you can buy like a
commercial grade drone that is just the
the motors with no sophisticated
computer that can fly however you want
the reason i brought it up and we don't
have to go back to this because you said
avocados are gonna get more expensive
good good news but avocado and you said
if not if you unless you have a trade
route but i would feel like new
hampshire would if it was
seceded and somehow it would be cut off
and there would be all the trade routes
would be blockaded so i thought drones
but then i saw this and it's like yeah i
mean how many men does it take to block
off an entire state from the rest of the
country i mean that's a lot of policing
they could probably keep it up for like
a week or two weeks but it's going to be
futile i mean people are going to have
drones that are going to fly over them
and deliver stuff yeah people are going
to build tunnels i mean look at what's
happening on the border look at what's
happening in in palestine and israel if
people want to get through a wall
they'll get through it um soldiers march
on their bellies ian they're not going
to be able to lock down an entire border
yeah but i do think considering what
what drones will mean for this future is
something interesting so going back to
like ancient rome
it's interesting that when rome
collapses you get these the rise of
these different
latin languages you know what i mean
they're very similar but because they're
separate from each other they form their
own version of the language italian and
french are very similar but then spanish
and french are different but still you
can kind of see where they're similar
because everything fell apart and those
connections broke and the language has
changed but the interesting thing is
when you see like the collapse of of a
society or a plague or a major disaster
the technology remains
so i wonder if there are like
you know ultra-wealthy individuals who
are like that's what you know that's
what they want the idea would be you
have eight eight billion people all
working towards developing new
technology
let's say 90 of their ideas are trash
ideas and they're like let's make a
drone with a clock in it that way people
know what time it is when they fly and
you're like that's the stupidest idea
i've ever heard
so so they throw that one out but then
someone's like let's add you know uh
fixed wings to one of our drones so it
can both fly as a drone or you know
convert to a glider and people have done
things like that and you're like oh
that's interesting that could save power
when it's in glide mode and then convert
into a quadcopter by the wings turning
up interesting idea someone has done
that
so what happens then is when you have
all these good ideas built up
and there's a mass crisis of like a
civilization collapse or a plague
the technology and the literature and
all that stuff that allows you to build
it remains sometimes the romans lost um
aqueduct
making concrete underwater and you'd see
like new tribes of people moving into
old roman broken cities and like living
under the aqueducts for shade because
they didn't really know what they were
how to use them so technology was lost
for like hundreds of years and they say
that the romans had a way to make
concrete underwater we still don't know
so cool but the point is
you will lose let's let's say society
collapses by 80 percent and you lose 20
of the technology you then have a
renaissance after the black plague a
renaissance because the knowledge of how
to do things better still exists and you
know what you need and then all of a
sudden everyone's working and
contributing and
scary thoughts so store the data like in
orbit and like glass i like the idea
have you have you see have you played uh
horizon zero dawn no have you guys
played that no ah dude you guys gotta
play it's a good game i'm gonna spoil
the whole game for you it's it's fairly
old but basically you're like you play
as this young woman and there are these
robot animals everywhere like robot elk
and robot dinosaurs or whatever
and you like you know shoot critical
points and break them off and then try
and like break the machines and harvest
parts the story is
it's a it's it's a great story
some company created a self-replicating
military machine that would consume raw
materials and then build new machines
and it had no replica replicator limit
and they lost control of it and so it
was consuming resources endlessly and
expanding
and it was a military machine that could
you know attack and it was made for the
army so they couldn't stop it and then
eventually they were like
we know that this planet will die
these machines will eventually wipe out
all organic matter converting it into
these machines and there's nothing we
can do to stop it
so they come up with a plan
i think the pla i think the plan is
called zero dawn
and the plan was to build underground
bunkers
that would wait the amount of time
necessary until all biomass was
destroyed and the planet was eradicated
and all of these machines powered down
and then
re-terraformed the earth with seeded
life and the robot animals are the first
iteration of life like of of some kind
of life to start facilitating the
ecosystem and then human clones start
emerging and they're all like
tribalistic and not realizing it that's
a crazy game
yeah cool story huh wow that's crazy
yeah just wait it out
that's that's the age
just just wait it out
maybe that's what people need to do
today it's like go homestead and then
just
wait it out
maybe it takes it takes well
historically it could take like
thousands hundreds of years maybe
thousands hundreds of years but times
kind of speeds up sometimes too like if
you have more oh it's october more
access to what the space i was looking
at will of the people today i was doing
a sound check and so i just like i'll
play will of the people it's a song i
released and it was november 2nd 2020
yeah i'm live yeah it's been a year
dance that's why that's crazy man that's
crazy i guess when you're when you're
when you're locked up locked down and
the country's imploding you got you've
got a lot to do time flies huh they say
time flies when you're having fun but
i don't know we're just getting older
did you see the time flies with age
exactly yeah that one representative
wanted to pass a law that made guys get
vasectomies is that real
i mean it's just hyperbole where they're
like if you're going to control a
woman's body then we're going to chop
men's blood you're going to be
authoritarian then we're going to be
even more authoritarian yeah don't do
that by the way well look i'll put a
terrible plan
like there's no real law in that
it's just shock content
and and it's because they're talking to
each other
when like it's like we mentioned with
colbert doing the the vaccine shuffle
thing he's not talking any of us
that's not convincing in any way
so who's he talking to the people who
are already vaccinated there you go
who's this guy talking to the people who
already agree with them that's that's
the problem with two very distinct
cultures in this country and
that's where we're going baby
at least drones won't be falling out of
the sky
yet don't be so sure about that
yeah like wait for it i'm surprised we
didn't see videos like this sooner they
are coming down slowly people like
dodging out their emergency rotors are
kicked in i think when they come down
but they're just they're just being sent
home so they're turning off
yeah thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you